Hello everybody, this is Dr. Cutters, we're talking about immune boosters and immune modulators
in this video and what we're trying to do with phase one and or phase two Lyme disease.
So here's a product that I formulated for phase one or phase two Lyme.
You can use it in either.
Any of these products could be used in phase one or phase two Lyme.
This is what we call our acute LX.
It's got my otockey, it's got reishi mushroom, it's got burberry and cat's claws.
So cat's claw and burberry, very common immune boosters for killing Lyme.
Most people know about those, burberry is one of my favorite for gut health and for killing
H. Pylori and other bacteria in the gut.
It's really good for your heart.
It's really good for your vessels.
It's one product that I take, at least weekly I take burberry and I think it's one of my favorite
products of all the products.
Maybe only surpassed by the mushrooms, so I wrote a whole book on the mushrooms, you can download
it free on our site as well.
So the myotockey, reishi mushrooms and then are in this as well and the cat's claw is just
a favorite for Lyme disease.
And the chronic is just a little bit different.
We add some other things that are to the other acute.
So most people will take both the acute and the chronic together.
So kind of mislabel, we just figure out another label to put on it.
But it has some of the enzyme blends that help break down any of the barriers that these
biotoxins put up.
So that's one major issue in trying to kill Lyme disease is that the co-infections, not
just the burrelia, but the co-infections put up these barriers around themselves so the
immune system can't get at them.
So we use enzymes that specifically break down those barriers.
So that's what this has in it.
That would be more appropriate for chronic Lyme, somebody who has more than just got these
symptoms a couple days ago.
That's why we put it in this product.
It also has turkey tail, a different mushroom, it has wormwood, great for other parasites as
well.
It has a lot of lorin, which is a great product for phase 3, Lyme 2.
But then it has thymus to help build your immune system and sodium alginate, which is a great
binder for stuff in the gut so that you're not reabsorbing any endotoxin.
So as you kill Lyme disease, that's if these acute and chronic are made for, you need to
bind them in the gut.
I go over that in detail, addozium in our seven phases of detox book, as well as our seven
phase of detox course, which I recommend for anybody with chronic disease.
So you've got to be able to detox and get this stuff out of your body.
So that course is a must literally for anyone with any chronic disease whatsoever.
It is the seven phase of detox, so make sure you look into that as well.
And then, so by other favorites is our clear immunopac.
This is just a fantastic all around, if you don't have autoimmune disease to be taking on
a regular basis.
It has our clear immunoplus that we sell separately as well as our clear immunoplus, but which is
a great product.
I don't list that as something to take in here because it's in the clear immunopac.
So it comes in a box, it comes in individual packs, so it's really easy to take this stuff.
You got the clear immunoplus, which has all the great mushrooms and some binders in there.
Green TX tract to decrease the IL-6 production, endographies, elderberry, straggolus,
echinacea, all great immune stimulants.
Has the anacetyl cystine help with phase one and phase two detoxification pathways, intercellular
detoxifications or glutathione production, has your ADK complete, which is your really what
are your made immune modulators.
So it helps balance that immune response.
So you don't get a hyper immune response that you don't have a hyper immune response.
So it helps balance between TH1 and TH2, really necessary to help you with a proper
amount of vitamin D, as well as all the other fat soluble vitamins that I think I have some
videos on why you should take vitamin D along with all the other fat soluble supplements.
That's why we created this product.
Has vitamin C is an immune stimulator, again you do not take this product in phase three,
but this has not just the vitamin C, but all the other components that help work right
along with that, and it has zinc and some other minerals and supplements to help balance that.
So this is one of, this is really just a big all around favorite of mine and that again
mushrooms are just one of my favorites.
So our micro clear complete is our complete mushroom package.
So this has all the different immune stimulating mushrooms, a lot of these mushrooms also work
as adaptogens and can be really helpful for different organs, lions made can help with the
brain.
So you would technically mushrooms, technically all of these would fall into an immune modulator
and technically a lot of people with phase three lime can take this product.
So it can work as an immune modulator and I would recommend people in phase three lime with
antibodies to try to take this product because it can have such healing benefits for you.
It can help kill lime without so much stimulating the immune response to kill self tissue.
Some people that have self antibodies are able to take a mushroom blend and then we have to
go to specific mushrooms, like if they have serious brain issues that look at lions made.
That can help build neurons and help clean neurons.
Cordyceps for the lungs also cordyceps is a great adaptogen so can help with adaptogenic issues.
Turkey tail and some of the other mushrooms are could be more immune stimulating but many
times they can still work just as an immune modulator can be used that way as well.
So this is really a must, I mean I take this product on a daily basis.
It's just one of my favorite just to keep healthy.
So and then your paracler, which has sweet wormwood, has olive leaf, black walnut, hulls are
murmuring again and are unimissing it again but this was really created for more intestinal
type parasites because of the black walnut, hulls, but you have those core morbidity so often
with Lyme disease that it's just really a must for Lyme patients as well.
And then some of the standards for Lyme for phase one and phase two is biocytin.
Lyme's products are great and many times in a liquid form can be better absorbed for
people, easier to take for some people, certainly easier to take for children.
So think about this product in that case too, it's a good, they have it in pill form too
but I listed here the liquid because of its ease of being able to get in people that aren't
good at taking pills, especially young ones.
So these are some of the products you can think of, I could add in a bunch more but these
are some of the my favorites that you would think of in this line of immune stimulating and
trying to modulate the immune system so in phase one and phase two these are the things
that you think of.
All right, be blessed, continue on to the next videos.